♪♪♪
>> BEING A TOP MODEL
IS SO MUCH MORE THAN
FASHION, GLITZ AND GLAMOUR.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> IT'S HARD WORK.
YOU HAVE TO WALK THE WALK,
TALK THE TALK
AND BE ABLE TO DELIVER
ANYTIME, ANYPLACE, ANYWHERE.
BECOMING A TOP MODEL
APPEALS TO GIRLS
ALL OVER THE WORLD.
BUT NO MATTER
WHERE YOU COME FROM,
ONE THING IS FOR CERTAIN...
>> AAH!
>> BEING A TOP MODEL
TAKES A BEAUTY THAT RADIATES
INSIDE AND OUT.
>> GORGEOUS! GENIUS!
>> FOR THE EIGHTH CYCLE
OF "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
I INVITED 33 GIRLS
FROM ALL OVER THE COUNTRY
TO COME TO LOS ANGELES
AND SHOW ME
THEIR TOP MODEL POTENTIAL.
BUT FIRST, THEY HAD TO SURVIVE
MODEL BOOT CAMP WITH TWO OF THE
FIERCEST
DRILL SERGEANTS AROUND.
>> (cheering)
>> (calling cadence) POSE OFF!
>> AFTER SURVIVING BOOT CAMP,
THE GIRLS TRIED THEIR BEST
TO IMPRESS THE PANEL.
>> I JUST STARTED REALIZING
THAT I'M SUPPOSED TO BE A MODEL.
>> I'M VERY LIKABLE.
>> I ALWAYS GOT THIS ATTITUDE.
>> IN THE END,
I CHOSE 13 GIRLS
TO COMPETE FOR THEIR DREAM,
INCLUDING A "TOP MODEL" FIRST,
AS TWO FULL-FIGURED GIRLS
MADE IT INTO THE HOUSE.
>> (cheering)
>> A.N.T.M. UP!
>> NOW ONLY FIVE GIRLS REMAIN--
BRITTANY,
DIONNE,
NATASHA,
JASLENE
AND RENEE.
TONIGHT,
WE'LL REVISIT HOW WE WENT
FROM 13 LUCKY HOPEFULS
TO THE FINAL FIVE,
WITH SOME "TOP MODEL" MOMENTS
YOU'VE NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
FOR SOME,
IT WAS ALL FUN AND GAMES.
>> (imitates speaking Russian)
>> SHE'S SCARING ME.
>> WHILE FOR OTHERS,
IT WAS A FIGHT.
>> YOU WANNA GET UP IN MY FACE?
>> BITCH, I'M-A PUNCH YOUR ASS
IN YOUR... FACE!
>> DIONNE. DIONNE, CHILL. CHILL.
IT AIN'T WORTH IT.
>> YOU WANT TO BE ON TOP?
♪♪♪
>> NO SOONER HAD THEY ARRIVED
IN HOLLYWOOD, CALIFORNIA,
THE 13 LUCKY GIRLS
HIT THE GROUND RUNNING
WITH THEIR FIRST PHOTO SHOOT,
WHERE THEY WERE ASKED
TO TAKE A STAND
ON CONTROVERSIAL
POLITICAL TOPICS.
>> I NEED TO KNOW, LIKE,
HOW DO YOU DO ANTIFUR?
LIKE, DO I LOOK LIKE
THE FURS STINK?
LIKE, UGH, I HATE FUR.
>> SOME GIRLS
EMBRACED THEIR CAUSES...
(camera shutter snapping)
>> THANK YOU. WELL DONE.
>> WHILE OTHERS FELL FLAT.
>> YOU'RE GONNA BE STANDING
UP THERE--THIS IS WHAT YOU
LOOK LIKE--A PSYCHO, LIKE...
(imitates "Psycho" theme)
DO YOU SEE WHAT I'M SAYING?
>> OH, GOD!
>> YEAH!
>> THEIR REWARD
FOR A LONG DAY OF WORK
WAS THE KEY
TO THE TOP MODEL HOUSE.
>> HOW HOT THIS HOUSE IS
IS RIDICULOUS.
LIKE... UGH!
>> AAH! WHOO!
(glass shatters)
>> AAH!
>> EAGER TO PUT
THEIR IN-HOUSE RUNWAY
TO GOOD USE,
THE GIRLS STAGED A FASHION SHOW
IN THIS NEVER-BEFORE-SEEN
MOMENT.
>> EVERYONE HAS TO DRESS UP,
LIKE, TOTALLY OPPOSITE
FROM WHAT YOU ARE.
CASSANDRA WAS A, UM,
RUSSIAN GIRL...
>> (imitates Russian accent)
PLEASE, QUIET DOWN.
>> NATASHA IS A BLACK GIRL...
>> MAMA,
YOU GOT A BIG PADUNKADUNK.
>> (laughs)
>> I WAS A WHITE GIRL...
I GOTTA HAVE A NAME NOW.
>> YOU'RE TIFFANY.
>> SARAH, WHO'S, LIKE,
SO CUTE AND NICE,
IS LIKE CRAZY, OUT-THERE JAEL.
>> I LIKE THE HAIR.
>> HELLO, LADIES.
WELCOME TO OUR TOP MODEL-PACKED
FASHION SHOW.
LET ME INTRODUCE YOU
TO THE JUDGES.
ON MY LEFT,
WE HAVE GRANDPA STEVE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> (laughs)
IN THE MIDDLE--BABY TYRA.
AND ON MY RIGHT,
WE HAVE MISCHA BARTON.
AND MY BEAUTIFUL BORICUA,
CHA-CHA DIVA.
(laughs)
>> SO HERE WE GO.
OUR FIRST MODEL IS GRANDMA!
>> THAT'S RIGHT!
>> COME ON, GRANDMA!
WE GOT GRANDMA
IN HER PLEATHER BLACK DRESS.
OUR NEXT MODEL--
WE HAVE TANESHA,
MISS PROJECT CHECK
FROM THE BRONX.
WORKING IT, BABY,
WITH HER 'FRO
AND HER MILITARY JACKET.
>> HEY, I GOT A QUESTION
FOR YOU.
>> YO?
>> HOW MANY LETTERS
ARE IN THE ALPHABET?
>> IT DEPENDS ON MY MOOD. YEAH!
>> OKAY.
>> ALL RIGHT,
OUR NEXT MODEL IS FROM RUSSIA.
HER NAME IS IVONIKA.
(laughter)
>> YES!
>> WORK IT! WORK IT!
>> WORK IT, BABY! WORK IT!
>> JUDGES?
>> (imitating Russian accent) I
HAVE ARRIVED.
TELL ME WHAT YOU THINK
OF MY OUTFIT, MYSELF.
YOU TELL ME WHAT.
>> OKAY, YOU HAVE TO BE QUIET
FOR US TO SPEAK.
>> (imitates speaking Russian)
>> SHE'S SCARING ME.
>> I RULE THIS WORLD.
(laughter)
>> OH!
>> OUR NEXT MODEL HAILS
STRAIGHT FROM THE IVY LEAGUE.
HER NAME IS TIFFANY.
>> HI! MY NAME'S TIFFANY!
IT'S GREAT TO MEET YOU GUYS!
OH, MY GOD!
>> I HAVE ONE QUESTION.
I HAVE ONE QUESTION.
HOW MUCH DID YOU PAY
FOR YOUR BAG?
>> $3,000. (scoffs)
>> YOU SHOULD'VE PUT THAT
TOWARDS YOUR LOBOTOMY.
>> (laughs)
>> (imitates crying) DADDY!
>> ALL RIGHT,
LET'S GET SERIOUS, LADIES,
LET'S GET SERIOUS.
IT'S JUDGING TIME.
>> WE HAVE DECIDED
THAT NEITHER ONE OF YOU WIN.
>> (imitates Russian accent)
WHAT? WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
>> OUR AGENTS
ARE GOING TO PAY YOU
NOT TO TAKE THE CONTRACT
BECAUSE THEY'RE SCARED
THAT YOU'RE GONNA
RUIN THEIR REPUTATION.
>> (imitates Russian accent)
I AM FROM RUSSIA.
I'M OUT OF HERE!
I DON'T NEED... SCREW!
(laughter)
♪♪♪
>> THEN IT WAS TIME
TO PUT FUN AND GAMES ASIDE
AS THAT WEEK'S PHOTO SHOOT
TURNED OUT TO BE
A MAJOR DISAPPOINTMENT.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU,
I AM PROBABLY
THE LEAST SATISFIED
THAT I'VE EVER BEEN
FOR A PHOTO SHOOT.
KATHLEEN'S SHAKY GRASP
ON HER ISSUE
DID NOT GO UNNOTICED...
>> I THINK THAT YOU DIDN'T
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND
THE CONCEPT.
>> AND RIGHT NOW
YOU JUST LOOK LIKE...
(imitates Kathleen) I DON'T
KNOW.
>> I KNOW, RIGHT?
>> AND SHE WAS
THE FIRST TO BE SENT HOME.
JAEL.
>> I'M VERY SAD.
BUT MAYBE THIS WAS--WAS NOT
WHAT GOD HAD PLANNED FOR ME,
YOU KNOW?
MAYBE I HAVE
A WHOLE OTHER WAY TO GO.
♪♪♪
>> AFTER THE FIRST ELIMINATION,
JAEL DECIDED
TO LET HER HAIR DOWN
AND BLOW OFF A LITTLE STEAM.
♪♪♪
>> WHY YOU ALL IN MY GRILLE?
>> JAEL IS GOING NUTS OUT THERE.
I'M, LIKE, WORRIED. (laughs)
>> YOU ARE CRAZY.
>> JAEL'S NOT TALKING FOR ONCE.
WE'RE REALLY SCARED. (laughs)
>> (laughing) OKAY.
>> (laughs)
>> DUDE, DO NOT HIT ME IN THE
FACE
WITH THOSE THINGS.
JAEL REMINDS ME
OF A FEMALE KRAMER,
TO TELL YOU THE TRUTH.
SHE IS VERY, VERY CRAZY.
SHE IS VERY, VERY OUT THERE.
SERIOUSLY.
I'M, LIKE, DONE WITH THAT.
IT WAS FUNNY FOR, LIKE,
ONE MINUTE.
I JUST WISH
THAT SHE WOULD, LIKE, JUST STOP
JUST FOR FIVE MINUTES.
JUST GIVE US SOME PEACE, PLEASE.
YOU'RE LIKE A HEMORRHOID,
YOU KNOW THAT?
(laughter)
>> (whispers) YOU CAN'T
GET RID OF ME!
>> FOR RENEE,
THE HONEYMOON WAS OVER,
AND SHE DECIDED
TO DISTANCE HERSELF
FROM FREE-SPIRITED JAEL.
>> I DID END UP SWITCHING ROOMS
BECAUSE I COULD JUST
FORESEE SOME PROBLEMS,
LIKE, WITH JAEL AND I.
AND SO I WAS JUST TRYING
TO NIP IT IN THE BUD
BEFORE IT HAPPENED.
>> WHY YOU MOVE
YOUR STUFF OUT THEN?
WHY?
>> I JUST KNOW WHEN I NEED MY
SPACE AND...
>> WELL, SAY SOMETHING, MAN.
>> SHE'S A FUNNY GIRL.
ONE MINUTE, SHE'S, LIKE,
HAPPY, CRAZY JAEL.
THE NEXT MINUTE, SHE IS, LIKE,
SNAPPING AND BARKING ORDERS.
JAEL, IT'S--IT WASN'T
A BIG DEAL.
I JUST, LIKE--
>> IT IS TO ME BECAUSE YOU AND I
HAVE BEEN CLOSER THAN...
>> THAN WHAT?
>> THAN OTHER PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN HERE, YOU KNOW?
>> I KNOW. I REALIZE THAT, JAEL.
>> WHY YOU MOVE YOUR STUFF OUT
THEN?
>> HUH?
JAEL, I'M MOVING MY STUFF
INTO THIS ROOM
SO I CAN GET SOME MORE SLEEP.
SOMETIMES I JUST WISH
THAT SHE WOULD JUST SHUT UP.
>> COMING UP, JASLENE
SETS THE GIRLS STRAIGHT.
>> THE THING IS, WITH ME,
I'M VERY BLUNT,
AND I WILL TELL YOU OUT LOUD.
>> AND LATER, DIONNE REACHES
HER BREAKING POINT WITH RENEE.
>> WHY ARE YOU
GETTING UP IN OUR FACE,
TELLING US WE'RE FAKE?
YOU DON'T KNOW ME.
>> 'CAUSE YOU ARE FAKE!
YOU ARE FAKE!
>> LATER THAT WEEK,
MISS J. TOOK THE GIRLS
STRAIGHT BACK TO HIGH SCHOOL
FOR RUNWAY 101.
>> MY SISTERS
ALWAYS GIVE SO MUCH EXTRA.
>> (laughs)
>> AND YOUR RIGHT ARM DOES MOVE,
DOESN'T IT?
'CAUSE IT'S AS STIFF AS A BOARD.
>> (laughs)
WHEN I WATCH THESE GIRLS WALK,
IT'S SO FUNNY TO ME.
I MEAN, JUST 'CAUSE I'M THE BEST
ONCE I GET OUT THERE.
>> THEIR SKILLS
WERE PUT TO THE TEST
IN FRONT OF THE STUDENT BODY.
>> WHOO!
>> NOW WILL YOUR MAMA
LET YOU WEAR THESE DRESSES?
>> MY DRESS NEEDS TO BE BURNED
BECAUSE IT WAS
PRETTY MUCH A SHIRT.
I KNOW THAT I WOULD'VE
NOT BEEN ALLOWED TO GO TO PROM
IN THAT IN ALABAMA.
>> AND SARAH'S
WARDROBE MALFUNCTION
INSPIRED SCHOOL SPIRIT.
>> (cheering)
>> LOOK IT! AW, MAN.
>> I'M WALKING DOWN THE STAGE
AND BINK!
MY BOOBS POP OUT.
WHEN I'M ONSTAGE, IT'S, LIKE,
I DON'T THINK ABOUT
THE AUDIENCE.
I THINK ABOUT WHAT I'M DOING.
>> BUT IT WAS JASLENE
WHO FELL SHORT
AT THE CHALLENGE.
(brakes screech, crash)
>> JASLENE, I ACTUALLY THOUGHT
THAT YOU WERE PRETTY LOST
ON THE RUNWAY.
YOU MADE PROBABLY
THE MOST MISTAKES.
>> WHEN HE TELLS ME
HIS CRITICISM,
I WAS IN SHOCK,
AND I FEEL LIKE
I'M READY TO KILL SOMEBODY.
>> AFTER THE CHALLENGE,
TENSIONS WERE RUNNING HIGH
IN THE HOUSE.
>> ATTITUDES IS CHANGING
REAL QUICK, AND I FEEL IT.
>> OH, YEAH.
>> PEOPLE MAD 'CAUSE THEY NOT
AT THE TOP NO MORE.
>> I COULD HEAR FELICIA
IN THE CORNER, TALKING,
AND IMMEDIATELY
I PUT MY GUARDS UP
BECAUSE I KNEW IT WAS
GOING TOWARDS ME.
>> AND YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT,
OH, YOU'RE FEELING THE TENSION
AND EVERYBODY.
JUST SAYING, LIKE...
>> SO WHAT'S THE...
>> WHILE YOU KEEP
TALKING ABOUT IT...
>> YOUR POINT IS?
>> 'CAUSE YOU NEED TO SHUT UP
ALREADY.
YOU'RE INTERROGATING THE
SITUATION.
>> I GUESS, JASLENE.
>> I FEEL LIKE
EVERYBODY'S BEING SO PHONY.
LIKE, THAT'S WHY I'M NOT AFRAID
TO SAY WHAT I HAVE TO SAY,
BECAUSE, LIKE--
>> NO, I UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT FOR ME, I'M--
>> PEOPLE MIGHT BE SITTING HERE,
SMILING AT YOU, BUT LATER ON,
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT YOU.
THE THING IS, WITH ME,
I'M VERY BLUNT,
AND I WILL TELL YOU OUT LOUD.
>> YEAH.
>> THAT'S THE THING.
I DON'T NEED TO TALK ABOUT
NOBODY BEHIND THEIR BACK.
I WILL TELL YOU IN YOUR FACE.
I DO FEEL LIKE I HAVE TO PUT MY
GUARDS UP AT ALL TIMES,
ESPECIALLY WITH THE COMPETITION
AND HOW PHONY THESE GIRLS CAN
BE.
>> AND IN THIS
NEVER-BEFORE-SEEN FOOTAGE,
I SENT THE GIRLS
OUT ON A PICNIC TO UNWIND.
>> IT'S CALLED A BANANA SPLIT.
>> JASLENE,
ARE YOU TRYING TO GO UNDER?
>> AAH!
AAH!
>> (laughing)
>> AAH!
(laughs) OH, MY GOD!
>> JASLENE LET DOWN
HER COMPETITIVE GUARD
AND OPENED UP TO CASSANDRA.
>> I'M HAPPY WHEN I'M MODELING.
I SWEAR, NOTHING FULFILLS ME
LIKE MODELING DOES.
>> WOW.
>> WHEN I SEEN HOW GOOD I WAS
AND HOW GOOD I INTIMIDATED
THOSE GIRLS HERE...
>> (laughs)
>> AND IT--IT ONLY SHOWED ME
THAT HOW MUCH I'M WORTH.
CASSANDRA--SHE'S JUST
VERY UNDERSTANDING.
SHE'S A GREAT PERSON.
YOU KNOW, A GREAT PERSON
TO TALK TO.
>> YEAH.
>> FOR ME TO BE HERE,
IT WAS ALL GOD'S TIMING.
>> YEAH, IT IS.
>> LIKE, HOW I DIDN'T MAKE IT IN
CYCLE 7.
>> MM.
>> BUT WHY?
BECAUSE, GIRL,
YOU NEED YOUR THERAPY,
AND LOOK AT WHAT YOU LEARNED,
THE GIRL WHO YOU'VE BECOME
BECAUSE OF THAT, YOU KNOW?
>> YEAH.
>> AND IT'S, LIKE...
>> THAT'S GOD.
>> GIRL, IT'S GOD.
>> JASLENE--SHE'S STRONG,
SO SHE'S DEEPER THAN JUST
WHAT YOU SEE ON THE SURFACE,
AND I LIKE PEOPLE WHO ARE DEEP.
>> I WOULD GIVE
ANYTHING IN THE WORLD
TO PUSH MY KID ON A SWING.
>> WE HAVE TO HEAR IT ALL THE
TIME
ABOUT RENEE'S, LIKE, BABY,
AND HOW SHE MISSES HIM.
>> I WOULD GIVE ANYTHING
TO TAKE MY KID TO THE PARK RIGHT
NOW.
>> AND SHE DOESN'T HAVE
AN "OFF" BUTTON...EVER.
>> LATER THAT WEEK,
THE GIRLS WENT BACK TO CLASS
FOR A PHOTO SHOOT
ABOUT HIGH SCHOOL CLICHéS.
>> I AM CHOSEN TO PLAY THE NERD.
>> LIKE, REALLY LAUGH.
>> (laughs)
>> YEAH. THERE YOU GO.
>> SHE IS NOT PLAYING.
LOOK AT THIS GIRL WORK.
>> I HAD THE UGLIEST LOOK,
AND I STILL WORKED IT.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> GOING THROUGH HAIR AND MAKEUP
CAN SOMETIMES
BE A DANGEROUS EXPERIENCE.
>> I SAT IN THIS CHAIR,
AND TWO GIRLS TRIED
TO DO MY HAIR REAL QUICK...
AAH!
I HAD MY EAR FRIED
BECAUSE OF THEM.
I COULDN'T THINK ABOUT ANYTHING
ELSE
BUT THE AWFUL PAIN.
>> ARE YOU OKAY, NATASHA?
THAT COULD BE, LIKE,
A THIRD-DEGREE BURN 'CAUSE THE
SKIN IS OFF.
>> OH.
>> I STILL KNEW I NEED TO ROCK
ON THE PHOTO SHOOT.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> NATASHA, I DON'T THINK
THE SITTING IS WORKING AT ALL.
A LITTLE MORE GRACEFUL WITH THAT
LEG.
SEE HOW THIS LOOKS AWKWARD?
(camera shutter snaps)
>> SMALL-TOWN GIRL SAMANTHA
HAD A HARD TIME
TAPPING INTO HER BAD SIDE.
>> PRETEND YOU'RE TOTALLY ALONE
AND YOU'RE... (boing)
>> OH, MY GOSH,
HE JUST SAID... (boing)
>> EVERYBODY DOES IT!
>> (laughs)
>> I MEAN, THAT'S JUST, TO ME,
SOMETHING THAT YOU WOULDN'T TALK
ABOUT, HONESTLY.
BUT THAT'S JUST ME.
OTHER PEOPLE ARE A LOT MORE OPEN
THAN I AM, I GUESS.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> SAMANTHA'S INABILITY
TO TAKE ON DIFFERENT CHARACTERS
WAS A PROBLEM FOR THE JUDGES...
I SAW YOUR FILM, AND YOU DID DO
SOME MORE SEXY STUFF.
YOU JUST SEEMED SO UNSURE.
"I THINK I'M A HO?"
(laughter)
>> AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
>> I'M BUMMED OUT.
I THOUGHT I WOULD DO
A LITTLE BIT BETTER.
IT'S NOT LIKE I DON'T HAVE WHAT
IT TAKES. I JUST WASN'T READY.
>> AFTER A FEW WEEKS
IN THE COMPETITION,
ONE THING BECAME VERY CLEAR--
JAEL KNOWS HOW
TO WORK A HULA HOOP.
>> OOH!
HOOPS GET MAD.
HOOPS NEEDS TO BE BROKEN
IN THE MORNING.
(thud)
>> YOU LIKE THAT?
>> (laughs)
>> I CAN MAKE IT WHATEVER I
WANT.
♪♪♪
>> WHOO!
(cheers and applause)
>> WHEN IT CAME TIME
FOR MAKEOVERS,
I GOT THE GIRLS UP
AT THE CRACK OF DAWN
TO BE SURE
THAT THEY REALLY WANTED THEM.
I DON'T KNOW. DO YOU WANT 'EM?
>> YEAH!
>> TELL ME AGAIN
THAT YOU NEED 'EM.
>> WE NEED MAKEOVERS!
>> FOR SOME OF THE GIRLS,
NEW HAIR MEANT NEW CONFIDENCE.
>> WE WERE, LIKE,
WE DON'T CARE! JUST FIX IT!
>> THE COLOR--IT REALLY
BRINGS OUT MY FACIAL FEATURES.
IT REALLY IS AWESOME.
>> FOR BRITTANY,
BEAUTY MEANT PAIN.
>> JUST A LITTLE BIT OF PAIN!
OH, YEAH.
>> TRY AND HANG IN THERE.
>> (inhales deeply)
I WAS IN PAIN TODAY.
I WOULD JUST NEVER
PUT FAKE HAIR IN MY...
(laughs) ON MY HEAD.
I'D JUST WAIT UNTIL IT GREW.
>> BUT JAEL SUFFERED THE MOST
FOR HER NEW LOOK.
>> I JUST HAD A CALL WITH TYRA.
THE BRAIDED WEAVE
ONLY COMES SO HIGH,
AND THEN WE HAD TO GLUE
MULTIPLE TRACKS IN.
IT'S KIND OF BRINGING YOU
DOWN A LITTLE.
WE'RE GONNA
TAKE THE WHOLE THING OUT.
>> I HAVE NEVER
HAD TO GO THROUGH THAT ORDEAL
OF GETTING MY HAIR DONE
AND HAVING TO TAKE IT OUT
THE SAME DAY YOU GET IT PUT IN.
LIKE, THAT'S ABSOLUTE HELL.
>> OH, GOD.
>> JAEL--I FEEL SO BAD FOR HER.
SHE'S UPSET BECAUSE SHE JUST
SAT THERE FOR EIGHT HOURS.
>> YOUR HAIR LOOKS HEALTHY.
>> NO!
>> I DO LIKE MY HAIR.
I HAVE TO GET USED TO IT,
BUT I CAN ROCK ANY HAIR.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> I'M A ROCKER.
>> BRITTANY'S PAINFUL WEAVE
SOON BECAME EVERYONE'S PROBLEM.
>> MY HEAD HURTS SO BAD.
IT JUST HURTS.
I DON'T WANT
TO BE WHINY ABOUT IT.
IT'S REALLY JUST VERY STRESSFUL.
THE WHOLE SITUATION
IS STRESSFUL.
GOD, IT ITCHES SO BAD.
(sighs)
I JUST POKED MYSELF,
AND IT SENT CHILLS
DOWN MY SPINE.
>> (cries)
(thud)
>> OW!
>> WHY YOU JUST BE CRYING
ALL THE TIME, MAN?
I CAN'T EVEN TAKE THAT.
AND I KNOW A LOT OF GIRLS
ARE SAYING IT, TOO.
BRITTANY IS REALLY GETTING ON
A LOT OF FOLKS' NERVES.
SHE WANTS TO CRY
AND SHE WANTS TO RECEIVE
EVERYBODY'S SYMPATHY.
WHEN I HEAR A GIRL BOOHOOING,
SHE'S CRYING BECAUSE
HER BOYFRIEND JUST GOT SHOT.
OR WE WERE CRYING BECAUSE
OUR ROOMMATE JUST GOT SHOT
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
PEOPLE DON'T CRY
OVER EVERY LITTLE THING.
PEOPLE CRY ABOUT MAJOR STUFF
THAT'S HAPPENING IN THEIR LIVES.
I TOLD HER HOW IT WAS,
AND I SAID, END OF STORY,
AND I SLAPPED HER UP
AND I GAVE HER THE DEUCES
AND I WALKED AWAY.
>> BUT NO ONE WAS MORE ANNOYED
THAN RENEE.
>> I SWEAR TO GOD,
I'M GONNA KNOCK BRITTANY
ON HER ASS ONE OF THESE TIMES.
>> I CAN'T
STAND THE BITCH EITHER.
>> SOME OF THE GIRLS
APPARENTLY SEEM TO THINK
THAT I'M "ACTING" ALL THE TIME
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN GETTING
A LITTLE EMOTIONAL LATELY.
I DON'T LIKE CONFRONTING PEOPLE
ABOUT THINGS,
BUT I FELT LIKE
I SHOULD SAY SOMETHING.
>> LISTEN, I DO TALK...
I DON'T--I DON'T FEEL GUILTY
ABOUT TALKING...
WE'RE LIVING IN THE SAME HOUSE.
IT'S INEVITABLE.
>> BRITTANY,
IF I DON'T LIKE YOU--
IF I DON'T LIKE
SOMEBODY IN THIS HOUSE,
THEY KNOW I DON'T LIKE THEM.
>> OKAY.
>> I'M NOT FAKE
TO ANYBODY'S FACE.
>> OKAY. THEN... COOL.
>> THE PHOTO SHOOT
WAS ALL ABOUT
BECOMING SWEET TREATS...
>> (laughs)
>> WITH VERY LITTLE LEFT
TO THE IMAGINATION.
>> NO.
(bell dings)
>> I'M FREEZING!
THAT'S WHY MY TEETH
ARE CHATTERING.
(camera shutter snapping)
>> LAST FRAME.
GOOD JOB, BRITTANY!
(camera shutter snaps)
>> WHEN THE ICE CREAM
SHE WAS HOLDING FROZE HER HAND,
CASSANDRA DIDN'T COMPLAIN.
>> (hisses)
>> SHOULDERS.
>> BRING A LITTLE MORE... AHH.
>> BUT LATER, HER SILENCE
HAD SOME CHILLY CONSEQUENCES.
>> I CAN'T FEEL MY HAND ANYMORE.
I DIDN'T DROP THE ICE CREAM
BECAUSE I DIDN'T WANNA
BE A-A PUNK,
SO I JUST HELD THE ICE CREAM.
MY HAND WENT NUMB,
AND I DIDN'T FEEL IT.
>> WOW, IT'S THAT SERIOUS?
>> MM-HMM, THE ICE CREAM
IS VERY COLD. LIKE, IT'S VERY
COLD TO HOLD FOR A LONG TIME.
>> YOU DIDN'T GET A FROSTBITE?
IS IT BAD?
>> I DID, AT THE ENDS,
WHERE THE PURPLE...
>> SHE'S LOOKING AT IT. (gasps)
>> THE PAIN IS THROBBING.
I MEAN, IT'S--IT'S SO INTENSE.
I NEED TO SEE A DOCTOR AT THIS
POINT, SO I GO TO THE HOSPITAL.
>> THE DOCTOR TELLS ME
THAT I HAVE FROSTBITE,
AND THERE'S NOTHING THAT THEY
CAN DO ABOUT IT.
I JUST HAVE TO WAIT
UNTIL THE SKIN HEALS.
HOPEFULLY, IT'LL BE BETTER
IN THREE OR FOUR DAYS.
>> AROUND THE SAME TIME,
NATASHA CAME DOWN
WITH A PAINFUL TOOTHACHE.
>> HERE'S OUR NERVE
ON THE WISDOM TOOTH.
>> MM-HMM.
>> AND THEN HERE'S OUR--
HERE'S OUR CAVITY,
THIS--THIS DARK SPOT RIGHT HERE.
THAT WOULD CAUSE
ALL OUR PROBLEMS
THAT YOU'VE BEEN DESCRIBING.
AND ONCE I TOOK THE X-RAY,
THE WISDOM TOOTH SHOWED
A VERY LARGE CAVITY.
IN A CASE LIKE THIS,
WE USUALLY HAVE TO DO
AN EXTRACTION.
I JUST WANT YOU TO KEEP TAKING
SOME DEEP BREATHS.
>> I CANNOT TAKE MEDICINE
BECAUSE IT MAKES ME FEEL SLEEPY.
>> IT'S DEFINITELY
LOOSENING UP.
>> OH! (groans)
>> (speaks indistinctly)
>> OH! (groaning)
>> OKAY.
>> (speaks indistinctly)
(crying)
>> WE'RE DONE?
>> WE'RE ALL DONE.
IN THE END,
YOU'RE NOT GONNA MISS IT.
IT'S NOT GONNA
MAKE ANY DIFFERENCE TO YOU
WHATSOEVER
WHETHER IT'S THERE OR NOT.
>> (crying) YEAH, OKAY.
>> OKAY?
>> I'M SORRY. YEAH.
I STILL HAVE A LOT OF PAIN,
SO IT PROBABLY WILL FEEL BETTER
IN COUPLE DAYS.
>> WHEN IT CAME TIME
FOR ELIMINATION,
IN SPITE OF HER STRENGTH OF
CHARACTER,
THE JUDGES FELT CASSANDRA'S
ATTEMPTED FIERCENESS
WAS A FROZEN FLOP...
YOU'RE A GIRL
THAT KEEPS CONTINUING TO LOSE
YOUR PRETTY.
SO, LIKE, YOU'RE GROWLING
AND YOU'RE LIKE... (growling)
>> IT'S HARD TO STAY PRETTY
WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO BE...
>> BUT YOU'RE DOING IT
RIGHT NOW.
YOU JUST WENT... (growls)
INSTEAD OF... (growls)
AND SHE WAS ELIMINATED.
>> (speaks indistinctly)
>> IT MAKES ME FEEL BAD
BECAUSE I KNOW I CAN DO IT.
I NEED MORE MIRROR TIME
AND I NEED TO PRACTICE MORE.
>> COMING UP,
RENEE GOES TOE-TO-TOE
WITH DIONNE.
>> YOU BE IN
EVERYBODY'S... BUSINESS!
>> YOU WANNA GET UP IN MY FACE?
>> BITCH, I'M-A PUNCH YOUR ASS
IN YOUR... FACE!
>> DIONNE. DIONNE, CHILL. CHILL.
>> ALTHOUGH RENEE AND BRITTANY
HAD THEIR DIFFERENCES...
>> I SWEAR TO GOD,
I'M GONNA KNOCK BRITTANY
ON HER ASS ONE OF THESE TIMES.
>> THEY WERE SOON AGAIN
ACTING CHUMMY...
>> (laughs) I CAN'T BELIEVE
YOU JUST STARTED THAT.
IT'S SO FUNNY.
>> WHICH RUBBED DIONNE
THE WRONG WAY.
>> Y'ALL KILL ME WITH THESE...
ACTS Y'ALL WILL BE PUTTING ON.
Y'ALL BE ARGUING ONE DAY,
AND THE NEXT DAY, Y'ALL BE
UP IN EACH OTHER'S FACE LIKE...
LIKE IT'S ALL GOOD.
>> JUST BECAUSE
YOU DON'T HOLD A GRUDGE
DOESN'T MEAN THAT YOU'RE FAKE.
>> I'M NOT SAYING YOU
NECESSARILY
HAVE TO HOLD A GRUDGE.
I'M JUST SAYING IT'S JUST--
Y'ALL TWO JUST DO NOT SEEM
LIKE Y'ALL ARE REAL.
I MEAN, I-I HEAR Y'ALL
SAYING CERTAIN THINGS,
AND YOU'LL FLIP BACK AND FORTH.
>> THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
BEING ABLE TO RISE
TO THE MATURITY LEVEL
THAT'S NEEDED FOR THE TIME,
AND BEING ABLE
TO RELAX AND HAVE FUN.
IF I HAD A BEEF WITH HER,
WE'D TALK IT OUT--IT'S OVER,
IT'S SQUASHED, IT'S DONE.
WHY SHOULDN'T I BE NICE TO HER?
>> Y'ALL ARE LYING!
BECAUSE WHEN Y'ALL HAVE BEEF,
Y'ALL DO NOT... SQUASH IT.
>> WE DON'T BEEF!
>> I--DON'T EVEN DARE TELL ME...
>> FIVE MINUTES AGO!
>> WATCH! WATCH! WATCH!
A FEW DAYS FROM NOW, Y'ALL GONNA
BE TALKING ABOUT IT AGAIN.
SOMEBODY'S GON'
BRING SOMETHING UP,
AND ONE OF Y'ALL GONNA BE LIKE,
"OH, YEAH, WELL,
DA-DA, DA-DA, DA-DA, DA-DA."
WELL, Y'ALL NEED
TO STOP... LYING.
YOU DON'T KNOW ME.
>> 'CAUSE YOU ARE FAKE!
YOU ARE FAKE! YOU BE UP
IN EVERYBODY'S... BUSINESS!
YOU BE IN EVERYBODY'S...
BUSINESS!
>> YOU WANNA GET UP IN MY FACE?
>> BITCH, I'M-A PUNCH YOUR ASS
IN YOUR... FACE!
>> DIONNE. DIONNE, CHILL. CHILL.
DIONNE GETS PISSED.
DIONNE STANDS UP.
LIKE, SHE'S GETTING SO PISSED,
SHE'S READY TO TAKE THIS GIRL'S
HEAD OFF, AND I'M LIKE,
OH, JESUS, PLEASE DON'T LET THIS
BE NO BLOODBATH UP IN HERE.
>> THIS BITCH...
>> IT AIN'T WORTH IT.
>> YOU ALWAYS IN SOMEBODY'S
FACE!
YOU ALWAYS IN SOMEBODY'S FACE!
>> IT AIN'T WORTH IT.
DIONNE, IT AIN'T WORTH IT.
COME ON, THEY AIN'T WORTH IT.
I'M SERIOUS. IT AIN'T WORTH IT.
>> BITCH, YOU AND YOU CAN'T
STAY OUT OF NOBODY'S BUSINESS!
I'M SITTING BY MYSELF
ALL THE... TIME.
>> YOU DON'T CATCH ME
IN NOBODY'S...
Y'ALL AIN'T EVEN--
Y'ALL JUST FAKE!
>> DIONNE, SHE AIN'T WORTH IT.
>> Y'ALL JUST FAKE.
>> WITH TEMPERS FLARING
AT THE HOUSE,
THE GIRLS NEEDED TO GET OUT,
WHICH ONLY LEAD
TO MORE TROUBLE.
>> OH, GREAT.
WHAT HAVE WE GOTTEN OURSELVES
INTO?
TOP MODELS ALL GETTING ARRESTED.
>> WILL ALL OF YOU
PLEASE TURN AROUND
AND ASSUME THE POSITION
AGAINST THE CAR?
COULD YOU TURN AROUND
AND POSE FOR ME, PLEASE?
FAILURE TO USE YOUR WHOLE BODY.
TURN AROUND, PLEASE, AND POSE.
PIGEON-TOED.
IT'S NOT GONNA WORK.
TURN AROUND AND POSE, PLEASE.
FACE ISN'T IN IT.
IT'S NOT GONNA WORK.
YOU'RE SHOWING TOO MUCH NECK.
FAILURE TO EXECUTE THE POSE.
OVEREXAGGERATION OF THE POSE.
LADIES, PLEASE TURN AROUND.
I'M NOT ACTUALLY A TRAFFIC COP.
MY NAME IS BENNY NINJA,
AND I'M GOING TO BE
YOUR POSE COACH FOR TODAY.
>> (cheering)
>> THE GIRLS HAD A LOT TO LEARN
FROM POSING EXPERT BENNY NINJA.
>> WHATEVER POSITION YOU'RE IN,
EXAGGERATE IT.
YOU WANT A DIFFERENT SHOT
EACH TIME.
YOU DON'T WANNA
WASTE HIS ROLL OF FILM.
>> THEN IT WAS TIME
TO COMMIT A CRIME OF FASHION
TO PUT THEIR POSING SKILLS
TO THE TEST.
>> GO.
♪♪♪
>> THERE YOU GO.
OOH.
OOH, OOH, OOH.
>> THE MAZE IS VERY EASY FOR ME
BECAUSE I GOT TO USE
MY DANCE BACKGROUND.
(sensor buzzes)
(sounds buzzer)
(sensor buzzing)
>> GO.
>> WHEN I GO INTO
THE LASER MAZE CHALLENGE,
WHAT I'M THINKING ABOUT IS,
POSE YOUR TAIL OFF
AND DO THE BEST JOB
THAT YOU POSSIBLY CAN.
>> CORRECT.
WHITNEY BLEW MY MIND.
HER POSES WERE PHENOMENAL.
FABULOUS, GIRL.
>> (laughs)
>> WHITNEY'S HARD WORK
AND ELEGANCE PAID OFF,
WINNING HER
A $40,000 DIAMOND BRACELET.
>> (gasps) OH!
>> YES!
>> WHOO!
>> YEAH!
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> OH, MY GOD!
(laughs)
>> CRIME WAS STILL
THE NAME OF THE GAME
AT A GRUESOME PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE THE GIRLS WERE MADE UP
AS FASHION CRIME SCENE VICTIMS.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> ONCE EVERYBODY STARTED
TO GET THEIR MAKEUP ON
AND EVERYTHING, I WAS SO INTO
LOOKING AT EVERYBODY.
(camera shutter snapping)
>> I HAVE SO LITTLE TO SAY!
THIS IS REALLY GOOD.
>> FELICIA SCARED
THE HELL OUT OF ME, THOUGH,
WITH HER--THAT NECK THING?!
IT LOOKED SO FREAKIN' DISEASED.
>> YOU'RE NOT LOOKING
INTO THE CAMERA.
YOU'RE JUST--
WE WANT A GLAZED-OVER PICTURE,
LIKE A DEAD BODY.
>> I'M THINKING ABOUT NOTHING
WHEN I'M POSING.
IT'S JUST--YOU'RE DEAD.
(chuckles)
>> THAT LOOKS LIKE YOU'RE TAKING
A NAP.
>> THERE YOU GO.
>> WE NEED IT TO LOOK LIKE
YOU WERE BRUTALLY KILLED.
>> YEAH.
>> BRING YOUR FACE THIS WAY.
>> I LOOK LIKE
A DEAD-ASS RICH WOMAN, FOR REAL.
MY DRESS WAS BLACK
AND SO SCANDALOUS.
>> THAT'S FEELING MODEL-Y.
BEND ONE OF YOUR LEGS...
LET YOUR ARM FLAP OVER THE POLE.
DIONNE TOOK A LITTLE WHILE
TO WARM UP,
AND SHE REALLY DIDN'T
TAKE MUCH INITIATIVE
TO IMPROVISE.
MUCH MORE BELIEVABLE.
>> BUT NEARLY EVERYONE
PULLED OFF AN AMAZING PHOTO.
>> IT'S KINDA SCARY.
EVERYBODY'S KINDA GOOD TODAY.
I THINK THE JUDGES ARE GONNA
HAVE A REALLY TOUGH TIME
BECAUSE EVERY GIRL HAS DELIVERED
IN A WAY THAT I NEVER EXPECTED.
♪♪♪
>> BACK AT PANEL,
THE JUDGES FOUND
THAT THE GIRLS
REALLY CAME ALIVE
WHEN THEY WERE PLAYING DEAD.
BUT FELICIA'S PHOTO
LACKED A REAL SPARK...
>> ALL THE OTHER GIRLS
HAVE MANAGED TO HAVE
SOME KIND OF SPARKLE EVEN IN
THIS SORT OF MORBID SITUATION.
AND I THINK IN THIS PICTURE,
I LOOK AT YOU,
AND YOU ACTUALLY JUST LOOK DEAD.
>> AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
>> (crying)
>> I'M SAD BECAUSE I EXPECTED
TO GO FARTHER THAN THIS,
BUT NOTHING AT ALL
IS GONNA KEEP ME
FROM FOLLOWING MY DREAM.
>> AS WITH PREVIOUS CYCLES,
THESE TOP MODELS JUST COULDN'T
KEEP A CLEAN HOUSE.
>> LOOK.
>> WHAT?
>> WELCOME TO THE OTHER SIDE
OF THE HOUSE.
>> (laughs)
>> OH, MY GOODNESS.
I KID YOU NOT, THIS BATHROOM--
IT IS, LIKE, NASTY.
NASTY, NASTY, NASTY, NASTY.
WHAT IS THIS BLACK STUFF? EW...
>> AND IT TOOK US
ABOUT TWO HOURS
FOR JUST ONE BATHROOM.
>> (laughs) IT'S SO GROSS.
>> YES.
TAKE A SHOWER.
>> IF I LIVED LIKE THAT,
I WOULD BE DIVORCED.
I SWEAR TO YOU,
MY HUSBAND WOULD DIVORCE ME.
>> "IF YOU DON'T HAVE
A FRIEND IN HERE,
MAKE ALL PURPOSE CLEANER
YOUR BEST FRIEND."
>> (laughs)
(bell dings)
>> THAT ONE'S A LITTLE MEAN.
>> I'M THE ONLY ONE
WITHOUT FRIENDS HERE.
>> HEY, COME ON.
EVERYBODY HAS FRIENDS.
>> (whispers) EVERYBODY BUT ME.
♪♪♪
>> THEN IT WAS TIME
TO SWITCH IT UP
AND HAVE THE GIRLS GET IN
A CROSS-DRESSING SHOOT WITH
SOME BEAUTIFUL DRAG QUEENS.
>> JASLENE DID A GREAT JOB
ON HER SHOOT.
>> I GOTTA FART...
(deep voice) LIKE A MAN.
>> WORK IT. THERE YOU GO!
(laughs)
>> WHILE HIP-HOP NATASHA
BLEW EVERYBODY AWAY.
>> (laughs) SAY "WUDITDO."
>> NATASHA, YOU MAKE A HOT MAN.
>> WHAT UP, MAN?
>> WUDITDO.
>> WUD-IT-DO.
>> WUDITDO, SHOTTA?
>> WUD-TO-DO, SHORTY?
(laughter)
>> WUD-IT-DO.
>> WHAT... IT... DO.
>> OH, OKAY.
>> WUDITDO, SHORTY?
>> WUDITDO, SHOTTA?
>> (laughing)
>> AAH! GOD!
>> YO, B., LET'S GO GET 'EM.
>> WHERE'S THE WIND?
>> YO, WIND FOR MY BITCH!
>> (laughing)
>> YEAH!
>> THAT'S GREAT. YEAH.
>> WAIT, OH, MY GOD, AND SHE'S--
>> GRABBING THE CROTCH,
VERY NICE.
OH, I LOVE THAT.
IT'S VERY BELIEVABLE.
(laughter)
>> WOW.
>> IT'S, UH...
>> OH. OOH, YEAH.
UGH!
>> YEAH.
>> OH, OKAY. OH, YEAH!
>> FOR DIANA, THOUGH,
THE SHOOT POSED
SOME DIFFICULT PROBLEMS.
>> SO YOU GUYS
ARE RED CARPET COUPLE.
>> HONESTLY, I DIDN'T THINK
IT WAS GONNA BE THAT DIFFICULT.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> DIANA, SHE IS OUTSHINING YOU.
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
>> YOU--YOU'RE JUST KIND OF
STANDING THERE LIKE THIS...
OKAY, LET'S GO...
>> HMM.
>> IT'S NOT INTERESTING.
I KNOW YOU'RE TRYING,
BUT IT LOOKS LIKE
YOU'RE BORED WITH IT.
>> OKAY.
>> THAT'S IT.
>> IN THE END, DIANA'S LACK
OF VISIBLE PASSION AND FIRE
LOST HER THE COMPETITION.
AND AFTER A TEARFUL GOOD-BYE,
SHE WAS SENT HOME.
♪♪♪
>> (crying) YOU KNOW,
ONE OF THEM'S GONNA BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
AND, UNFORTUNATELY,
IT'S NOT GONNA BE ME.
(sniffles)
BUT YOU WILL SEE ME AGAIN.
(laughs) YOU WILL.
>> COMING UP,
JAEL LOSES HER COOL.
>> YOU A DUMB BITCH.
NONE OF US LIKE YOU.
GO IN YOUR ROOM AND CRY.
>> AND LATER,
NATASHA HAS A JUDGING ROOM
OF HER OWN.
>> (imitates Tyra) IT MEANS I'M
BEAUTIFUL, TOO.
>> AFTER WEEKS
OF TOUGH COMPETITION,
THE GIRLS DRESSED TO IMPRESS
FOR A TOP HOLLYWOOD PARTY.
>> YOU GOTTA MAKE SURE
YOUR BOOTY LOOKS RIGHT.
♪♪♪
>> WHILE SOME GIRLS
MADE CONTACTS,
OTHERS WERE JUST OFF THE HOOK.
(whip cracking)
>> JAEL BEHAVED VERY, VERY BADLY
AT THE PARTY.
I DON'T REALLY FEEL LIKE
THAT'S THE WAY YOU SHOULD DO IT
AT A FASHION PARTY.
MAYBE IF THIS WAS
"GIRLS GONE WILD"?
(boing)
(whooshing sounds)
>> WHOO!
>> (laughs)
♪♪♪
>> YOU HAVE TO LIVE EVERY DAY
TO YOUR FULLEST
HERE IN THE "TOP MODEL" LAND.
(whip cracks)
>> BECAUSE IF YOU'RE CUT,
YOU WILL HAVE KNOWN
THAT THE DAY BEFORE
WAS THE BEST DAY
THAT YOU EVER HAD HERE.
>> NICOLE RICHIE
COULDN'T RESIST
STIRRING THE POT JUST A LITTLE.
>> THE BIGGEST ONE
WOULD HAVE TO BE...
PROBABLY JAEL. YOU SEE HER?
>> OH, OH, OH. YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
>> YEAH, THAT'S THE ONE
I DON'T LIKE.
>> I DIDN'T--I DON'T KNOW HER...
>> YEAH, BUT YOU--
>> BUT I-I--OH!
OH, I KNOW WHAT SHE LOOKS LIKE.
SHE HAS BLONDE HAIR...
>> YEAH.
>> SHE'S A MODEL.
>> THAT'S RENEE.
>> RENEE.
>> WELL, I DO FIND ONE OF MY
ROOMMATES
TO BE TWO-FACED,
AND SHE'S NOT ALLOWED
TO PULL THAT AROUND ME
ANY LONGER.
>> NICOLE RICHIE ASKED ME
WHO WAS THE CRAZY ONE
IN THE HOUSE, AND I SAID,
"JAEL IS THE CRAZY ONE
IN THE HOUSE."
>> IT'S REAL FUNNY
YOU'D SAY SUCH A THING
>> "WHO'S THE CRAZY ONE IN THE
HOUSE?
THAT ONE RIGHT THERE,
THE ONE THAT'S DANCING."
>> M'KAY.
>> SO YOU CAN
GET OUT OF MY FACE, BITCH.
>> I'M NOT IN YOUR FACE, BITCH.
>> HOW SHE GONNA TALK TO ME--
ABOUT ME--TO SOMEBODY?
ANYWAY...
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
>> I'M LIVING IN CRAZY LAND!
>> IS THAT FUNNY?
>> JAEL ALWAYS PREVAILS
IN ANY SITUATION.
SHE CAN CUSS YOU OUT UP AND
DOWN.
>> SHE SAID YOU...
>> (speaks indistinctly)
>> SHE SAID, "I HATE YOU."
I SAY, YOU A BITCH.
WE TIRED OF YOUR...
YOU A DUMB BITCH.
NONE OF US LIKE YOU.
GO IN YOUR ROOM AND CRY.
♪♪♪
>> THE NEXT PHOTO SHOOT
ALLOWED THE GIRLS
TO SHOW SOME DIFFERENT SIDES
OF THEMSELVES.
>> WE'RE GONNA DO
FOUR DIFFERENT SIDES
OF YOUR PERSONALITY.
WHEN YOU GO UPSTAIRS,
YOU ARE GOING TO BE DIRECTING
YOUR VERY OWN HAIR
AND YOUR OWN MAKEUP.
(camera shutter snapping)
>> SO, LIKE, FLOWY AND...
I WANT THIS SO BADLY
THAT IT GOES THROUGH MY HEAD
EVERY SINGLE TIME I GET ON SET,
AND I'M LIKE,
OKAY, I GOTTA DO GOOD. I GOTTA
DO GOOD,
AND I ALMOST FREAK MYSELF OUT.
>> THESE ARE PRETTY.
THEY'RE ALL POSED.
EVERY TIME I TELL YOU
TO STOP POSING,
YOUR PICTURES BECOME GENIUS.
YOU'RE POSING AGAIN.
YOU WANT ME TO MAKE YOU MAD?
WANNA GO HOME THIS WEEK?
>> NO.
>> USE THAT FRUSTRATION.
>> AAH!
>> AT PANEL,
SARAH WAS CRITICIZED
FOR NOT LETTING GO
AND HER LACK OF SPONTANEITY.
>> AND THEY DO LOOK POSED.
THEY DON'T LOOK NATURAL.
I THINK YOU DON'T
LET YOUR GUARD DOWN,
IS YOUR PROBLEM.
>> AND WHEN THE JUDGES FOUND
HER PICTURES
TOO CONTRIVED,
SHE WAS SENT HOME.
>> OH, MY LORD.
>> OH!
(sniffles)
I'M REALLY DISAPPOINTED.
I WANTED THIS SO BADLY.
I REALLY DID WANT THIS
MORE THAN ANYTHING.
BUT AT LEAST
I CAME OUT OF THIS COMPETITION
KNOWING THAT
IT'S OKAY TO BE MYSELF.
>> BECOMING A TOP MODEL MEANS
TAKING ON DIFFERENT CHARACTERS
ALL THE TIME.
SO THE GIRLS HAD
AN ACTING LESSON
WITH TIA MOWRY
AND TRIED ON SOME ROLES
THEY WERE VERY FAMILIAR WITH.
>> I WANT YOU GUYS TO IMITATE
THE JUDGES.
>> YEAH!
>> AH!
>> REMEMBER TO KEEP IN MIND
TO EMBODY THE CHARACTER
AND HOW THAT CHARACTER
WOULD MOVE.
>> (imitating British accent)
WHITNEY, LET'S TAKE A LOOK
AT YOUR PHOTO.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> OH!
I'M NOT QUITE SURE AT ALL
THAT IS A-A FASHION PHOTO.
>> FOR WHITNEY--
I LOVE YOU, GIRL.
YOU BE WORKING IT OUT,
ESPECIALLY FOR THE BLACK SISTAS.
>> (laughs)
(snaps fingers)
>> YOU BE DOING IT. WORK IT OUT.
>> GREAT JOB. ALL RIGHT, TYRA.
>> WHITNEY, DO YOU KNOW
HOW MANY BROWN SISTERS OUT THERE
ARE WATCHING YOU AND THINKING,
"SHE'S BEAUTIFUL.
IT MEANS I'M BEAUTIFUL, TOO"?
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> (imitating British accent)
THAT WALK...
>> SHE'S A MESS!
>> WAS ABSOLUTELY HORRIBLE.
>> YOUR TURN, JAY.
>> I AM THINKING,
WHITNEY, FOR YOU,
YOU HAVE THIS GREAT,
WONDERFUL PERSONALITY.
BUT THEN...
WHEN I TAKE YOUR PICTURE,
IT'S--IT--NONE OF IT
COMES THROUGH FOR ME,
AND IT MAKES ME WONDER
IF YOU REALLY ARE A MODEL.
♪♪♪
>> THIS PHOTO WILL REPRESENT
THE MODEL WHO WILL CONTINUE
IN THE COMPETITION.
I DON'T HAVE ANY PHOTOS.
IT'S A DOUBLE ELIMINATION
TONIGHT.
>> (imitates sobbing)
>> AW!
>> YEAH!
>> THEY WERE PUT TO THE TEST
BY EFREN RAMIREZ
OF "NAPOLEON DYNAMITE."
>> YOU'RE LATE! YOU'RE LATE!
I GOT TWO MINUTES
BEFORE THE SHOW BEGINS!
>> (melodramatically) THERE'S
TRAFFIC
ALL UP AND DOWN
FIFTH AVENUE.
>> (imitates Jamaican accent)
I'VE BEEN MODELING
FOR TEN YEARS,
AND THIS IS--THIS IS JUST
WHAT IT IS!
>> (imitates crying) THERE WAS
TRAFFIC UP AND DOWN
FIFTH AVENUE,
AND--AND I COULDN'T
DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT!
THIS ISN'T YOUR FIRST TIME
SHOWING IN NEW YORK, IS IT?
>> RENEE'S COMMITMENT
TO HER ROLE BOUGHT HER
HER FIRST CHALLENGE WIN.
>> YES!
I WON THE CHALLENGE,
AND I'M ABLE TO PICK A FRIEND,
AND, UH, I JUST PICKED DIONNE.
IT JUST FELT LIKE
THE RIGHT CHOICE.
>> THIS IS FOR YOU.
>> (gasps) WHAT THE...
>> AND THIS IS FOR YOU.
>> (laughs)
(record needle scratches)
>> A T-SHIRT? A T-SHIRT?!
WHAT YOU GONNA
DO WITH A T-SHIRT?!
(applause)
>> RENEE AND DIONNE'S
REAL PRIZE WAS
A VISIT FROM THEIR FAMILIES.
>> IS RENEE HERE?
>> WHAT THE HELL?!
AAH!
>> (crying)
>> I'M--I'M YOU'RE REAL PRIZE,
GIRL!
>> FINALLY,
JAEL HAD SOME PLAYMATES.
>> SHE'S CRAZY. DON'T GO TO HER.
>> I GOT TO PLAY WITH TA'KYA,
DIONNE'S DAUGHTER,
AND SHE'S SO AWESOME.
WHO IS IT?
>> (laughs)
>> OH, LITTLE BABY!
>> LOOK AT THAT POSE!
>> I LOVE THAT!
>> AND I GOT TO PLAY
WITH LITTLE TROY,
AND HE'S THE BEST.
LET'S MAKE NOISE. COME ON.
>> (babbling)
>> AND WE WERE HAVING
A PAPER PARTY,
AND WE WERE TEARING UP THE
PAPER.
NO. NO, NO, NO, YUCK.
>> YOU DON'T LET BABY
EAT DYED PAPER.
IT'S NOT GOOD. (laughs)
>> THEY'RE NO FUN.
THEY'RE GROWN-UPS.
>> (babbling)
>> YES. (growls)
>> (laughs)
>> JAEL IS LIKE A BIG KID,
SO, UM, HE'S HAVING
A REALLY GOOD TIME WITH HER,
AND I'M HAPPY
THAT HE'S HAVING A GOOD TIME.
>> SEE? EVERYTHING'S SO FUN
WHEN WE'RE WILD AND CRAZY.
>> (cooing)
>> SOMEBODY WHO'S
ON MY MIND SPEED OVER HERE.
>> (babbling)
>> IN WEEK EIGHT,
THE PHOTO SHOOT RECREATED
SOME CLASSIC "TOP MODEL"
MOMENTS,
AND THE GIRLS FROM PAST SEASONS
WERE ON HAND TO LEND SUPPORT.
>> AAH!
>> GIRL! OH, I LOVE YOU!
I'M PLAYING BRE,
WHO HAD GOTTEN HER GRANOLA BARS
STOLEN FROM HER.
NO!
(camera shutter snapping)
>> LONG NECK. LONG NECK.
>> WHITNEY IS PLAYING THE SCENE
WHERE I WAS IN PARIS
AT THE BUDDHA-BAR,
AND I REFUSED TO POSE NUDE.
I'M LIKE, NO!
>> (laughs)
>> NICE.
GIVE ME A GREAT FACE.
>> BRE TOOK ADVANTAGE
OF THE REUNION
TO MAKE AMENDS TO KIM
FOR PAST GRIEVANCES.
>> SERIOUSLY, KIM,
I FEEL LIKE YOU PLAYING
BOTH SIDES OF THE FENCE.
>> I'M PLAYING
NO SIDES OF THE FENCE.
YOU DON'T TRUST PEOPLE...
>> (scoffs)
>> AND YOU CAN TRUST ME.
>> AAH!
DON'T SAY ANOTHER WORD TO ME.
PLEASE DON'T.
KIM, SO LISTEN, RIGHT.
YOU KNOW I LOVE YOU.
I REALLY DID LIKE YOU
THROUGHOUT THE COMPETITION...
>> (laughs)
>> AND IT WAS THE STRESS.
HAD WE MET AT DIFFERENT TIMES,
WE'D BE BEST FRIENDS,
BUT I HAD TO COMPETE
AGAINST YOU.
YOU KNOW HOW CUTE YOU ARE?
I COULDN'T BE YOUR FRIEND.
YOU'RE PRETTY. SORRY.
>> AH, YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOUR APOLOGY
IS TOTALLY ACCEPTED.
IT IS--IT IS 100% OKAY.
>> WE HAD GOOD TIMES.
>> AND DIONNE
FACED AN ASSIGNMENT
SHE FOUND VERY CHALLENGING.
>> THE PERSON
THAT I HAVE TO PORTRAY IS KIM--
THE KISS IN THE LIMO.
AND I'M LIKE, HOLD UP...
(record needle scratches)
>> I'M NOT NO FREAKIN' LESBO.
>> YEAH! FOR ALL THE GIRLS!
>> YOU GOTTA LAY DOWN MORE.
>> THIS IS SO CRAZY
AND UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> DIONNE,
I WANT YOU TO GET INTO IT.
REMEMBER, YOU'RE PLAYING A
CHARACTER.
(camera shutter snapping)
>> THERE YOU GO, DIONNE!
>> AND HAVE NO IDEA
WHY I AM SO EXCITED
ABOUT BEING THIS CLOSE
TO A GIRL LIKE THAT,
AND I ACTUALLY FELT COMFORTABLE.
>> AT PANEL,
WHITNEY'S WINNING PERSONALITY
COULDN'T SAVE HER DULL PHOTO.
>> AS THEATRICAL AS YOU ARE,
YOU SHOW YOUR EMOTIONS
ON YOUR FACE... I DON'T QUITE
GET THAT SAME PASSION
IN THIS PICTURE.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK
HAPPENS TO YOU ON SET?
WHY DO YOU THINK YOU LOSE IT?
>> I THOUGHT THAT I HAD
A LOT OF ENERGY.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT
THAT WASN'T PORTRAYED
THROUGH MY FILM.
>> AND WHEN THE JUDGES FELT
HER PHOTOS LACKED PASSION,
SHE WAS SENT HOME.
YOU CAME A LONG WAY,
AND I THINK
YOU LEARNED A LOT HERE.
>> MM-HMM. I HAVE.
I THINK GIRLS HAVE GONE HOME
WHO'VE HAD BETTER PICTURES
THAN ME, BUT MY PERSONALITY
HAS HELD ME ON THE ENTIRE TIME.
AND IF I COULDN'T BE NUMBER ONE,
THEN I'M GLAD
TO BE NUMBER SEVEN.
>> COMING UP, THE GIRLS
SOAK UP SOME LOCAL COLOR
IN AUSTRALIA.
>> (imitates chicken clucking)
♪♪♪
(knock on door)
>> HI!
>> HEY!
>> WITH SIX GIRLS LEFT,
I SENT APRIL FROM CYCLE 2,
WHO'S BEEN DOING
CORRESPONDENT WORK,
TO TEACH THE GIRLS
ABOUT A SUBJECT
I'M VERY FAMILIAR WITH--
THE ART OF THE INTERVIEW.
>> I LIKE TO CALL IT
MY COYOTE EARS, WHERE IT'S,
LIKE,
CLOSE THE MOUTH...
(chomp)
>> PUT THE EARS UP.
(bell dings)
>> SO UP IN THE HOT SEAT,
WE HAVE JASLENE AND BRIT.
>> AND WHAT DO YOU
PRACTICE IN THE MIRROR?
>> I DON'T REALLY KNOW,
JUST SORT OF MOVEMENT.
VERY LITTLE.
>> (laughs)
>> LITTLE BIT TOO MUCH DEAD AIR.
>> THE NEXT DAY,
THE GIRLS WERE SURPRISED
BY ANOTHER VISIT FROM APRIL.
>> TODAY WE'RE GONNA
GIVE YOU GUYS A CHALLENGE.
I WANNA SEE IF YOU CAN
TAKE EVERYTHING
THAT I'VE TAUGHT YOU
AND HIT THE STREETS WITH IT.
>> BUT THAT WASN'T
THE REAL SURPRISE...
THIS CORRESPONDENT JOB
THAT APRIL IS TALKING ABOUT--
IN AUSTRALIA.
>> (screaming) OH, MY GOD!
>> OH!
>> AUSTRALIA!
LIKE, I'VE NEVER BEEN
NOWHERE ELSE BESIDES THE HOOD
AND AROUND THE CORNER.
>> (cheering)
>> (singsong voice) WE'RE GOING
TO AUSTRALIA!
♪♪♪
>> 24 HOURS LATER,
THE GIRLS
WERE POUNDING THE PAVEMENT
OF SYDNEY, AUSTRALIA,
PUTTING THEIR
NEW INTERVIEW SKILLS
TO THE TEST AND INCORPORATING
SOME AUSTRALIAN SLANG.
>> GOOD AVRO.
IT'S NENE HERE,
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS RENEE.
WE ARE IN BEAUTIFUL
SYDNEY, AUSTRALIA,
ON BONDI BEACH.
>> COMING TO YOU LIVE
FROM HYDE PARK.
>> HI. I'M JAEL,
AND I AM IN BLOODY AUSTRALIA.
>> HI, TYRA.
WE'RE HERE TODAY
IN SYDNEY, AUSTRALIA,
AT THE SYDNEY TOWN HALL,
BRINGING SEXY BACK
TO ALL THE AUSSIE BLUDGERS
AND ASKING THEM ABOUT THEIR, UH,
FASHION STYLE.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK
THE MOST MAJOR FAUX PAS
IN AMERICAN FASHION IS?
>> UM...
(record needle scratches)
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> FAVORITE AMERICAN COLOR.
>> RED AND BLUE.
>> YEAH, RED AND BLUE.
>> NO, IT'S ACTUALLY PINK.
>> WOULD YOU IMITATE A CHOOK
WITH ME?
(bell dings)
>> (imitates chicken clucking)
(record needle scratches)
>> THE REAL CHALLENGE
TURNED OUT TO BE
THE NEXT MORNING,
WHEN THE GIRLS STRUGGLED
WITH THEIR
COVERGIRL COMMERCIAL SHOOT.
>> TODAY
YOU GIRLS ARE GONNA BE DOING
A COVERGIRL COMMERCIAL
WITH A THICK AUSTRALIAN ACCENT.
>> OH!
>> OKAY, ROLL CAMERA!
>> SPEED.
>> ACTION.
>> (imitating Australian accent)
I WISH I COULD CAPTURE
THE DRAMA OF THE OUTBACK
IN MY LOOK.
>> SOME COULDN'T QUITE
GET THE ACCENT DOWN...
>> (imitating Australian accent)
I WISH I COULD CAPTURE
THE DRAMA OF THE OUTBACK
IN MY LOOK.
>> (imitating Australian
accent)I WISH I COULD CAPTURE
THE--
>> G'DAY, MATE!
>> WHILE OTHERS
JUST COULDN'T GET IT AT ALL.
>> I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS
BECAUSE I GOT RUN OVER BY A CAR
WHEN I WAS 17 YEARS OLD
AND IT AFFECTED
THE MEMORY PART OF MY BRAIN.
BUT I'M LEARNING
TO WORK WITH IT.
TAKE ONE.
(imitating Australian accent)
I WISH I COULD CAPTURE
THE DRAMA OF THE...
(blows raspberry)
I WISH... (blows raspberry)
(normal voice) TAKE 29.
(imitating Australian accent) I
WISH I COULD CAPTURE
THE DRAMA OF THE OUTBACK...
>> QUIET EVERYWHERE!
>> TAKE ONE!
(imitating Australian accent)
NEW QUEEN SHADOWS
WILL DO JUST THAT.
>> THAT'S GOOD. LET IT OUT.
>> (normal voice) THE COMMERCIAL
IS SO MUCH HARDER
THAN I THOUGHT IT WAS GONNA BE.
(imitating Australian accent)NEW
VIBRANT... UGH.
>> THAT'S OKAY.
>> (groans)
>> WE'RE GONNA SAY TAKE THREE.
READY?
>> (normal voice) TAKE THREE.
(imitating Australian accent) I
WISH I COULD FIND...
(normal voice) OH. TAKE 12.
(imitating Australian accent)
NEW QUEEN SHADOW WILL DO JUST...
WILL...
(normal voice) TAKE 15.
(imitating Australian accent)
THE VIBRANT COLOR
WILL BRING IN...
WILL ILLUMINATE...
>> IF YOU SAW YOURSELF
ON THE FILM,
YOU LOOKED GORGEOUS.
OH, AND--AND I SEE
YOU'RE TEARING UP,
AND I KNOW I'M--
I KNOW IT'S HARD.
IF I DON'T PREP YOU
AND GIVE YOU THE HARSH REALITY
OF WHERE IT IS NOW,
YOU'RE NOT GONNA GET
TO THAT END RESULT.
>> I FEEL LIKE SUCH AN IDIOT,
'CAUSE I'M NOT
THE GIRL NEXT DOOR,
AND I'M NOT, LIKE,
BUBBLY AND ALL THAT.
>> AT JUDGING,
THE PANEL COULD NOT SEE
THE COVERGIRL IN JAEL...
>> YOU COULD'VE SMILED,
'CAUSE YOU ALMOST LOOK MAD.
IT WAS ALMOST LIKE,
"UGH, NOW WHAT NEXT?
NOW WHAT'S MY NEXT LINE?"
>> BUT WHAT YOU
LOOKED LIKE TO ME
IS AN ANARCHIST
MAKING FUN OF BEING A COVERGIRL.
YOU HAVE TO BRING WHO YOU ARE
AND MARRY IT TO THE PRODUCT.
WE'RE NOT LOOKING FOR
COOKIE-CUTTER GIRLS.
AND JAEL WAS ELIMINATED.
>> I'M TREMENDOUSLY SAD
ABOUT LEAVING,
BUT I... I REALLY WISH
IT WASN'T OVER YET.
I'M NOT FINISHED
SPREADING HAPPINESS AND JOY
AND CHAOS THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
♪♪♪
>> NOW ONLY FIVE GIRLS
REMAIN...
JASLENE--THE SPICY LATINA
WITH THE FIERCE WALK
FROM CHICAGO...
NATASHA--
THE EVER-ENTHUSIASTIC RUSSIAN
WITH THE INFECTIOUS SMILE...
DIONNE--THE SASSY STUNNER
FROM MONTGOMERY, ALABAMA...
BRITTANY--
THE PHOTOGENIC BEAUTY
FROM SAVANNAH, GEORGIA...
AND RENEE--THE SEXY MOMMY
FROM MAUI, HAWAII.
YOU WON'T WANT TO MISS A MOMENT
AS WE FIND OUT
WHICH ONE WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> COMING UP
ON "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
WHEN IT'S TIME TO IMPRESS
THE DESIGNERS DOWN UNDER...
>> WHAT'S YOUR NAME AGAIN?
>> NENE.
>> I'M WAYWAY.
♪♪♪
>> BRITTANY LEAVES HER MANNERS
BEHIND.
>> IT'S NOT OKAY!
>> IT IS OKAY.
>> IT SUCKS BECAUSE
IT'S NOT MY... FAULT!
IT'S HIS, 'CAUSE I ASKED HIM
TO MEET ME OVER THERE.